clarifying questions yeah with that uh
russ yeah please take us away thank you
dominic
and thank you caroline and ben for
organizing this wonderful workshop
i'm excited to present some ongoing work
with susan and devorah about
counterfactual inference in sequential
experimental design uh i'm relatively
new to the field so
please pardon me if i miss something but
hopefully this will be a clear talk and
this will be a theoretical talk and as
bin likes to call it learning from
theoretical interventions
yeah so
sequential decision making problems uh
they are arising in more and more
domains ranging from online education
and online advertisements where you want
to enhance the teaching strategies or
like ad placements so in order to increa
make the learning better or increase
revenue
a particular application that
motivates this talk is mobile health
which has
become more and more common in the last
few years where
you try to use mobile applications to
notify
users and encourage them to engage in
healthy behavior so you can imagine
a mobile health application being some
sort of physical activity recommendation
app which once in a while sends you a
message to go take a walk or go out for
a run
and the way they measure activities
through some variable that they measure
the step counts and stuff like that
so let me
give a simplified but representative
setup of this kind of a trial we'll be
in the name and rubin potential outcome
framework so y-i-t-a
there are like three scripts but uh
hopefully it will be clear throughout
the talk uh potential outcome of user i
at time t under treatment a so those are
the three different
indices and the way these trials are set
up so this is like you're trying to
design an effective app so you're
running a trial beforehand to see
whether the work app works well or not
to optimize the app
and so for a capital t time periods at
each time you go through all the users
capital end users and you randomly send
them a notification or not
using some sort of policy so policy here
will be an n dimensional vector of
numbers between zero and one
and pi t i would denote the probability
of sending user i at time t a
notification given the history till time
t minus one
and once you send the notification or
not these are some preset times in the
day you observe some outcomes
so every user has a few
times decide in the day and at those
times you send them a notification or
not and then at the next 30 minutes for
example you measure their step count so
that would be this outcome and you have
some noise in there because maybe the
sensor is not perfect
and once you have once you have this
data for end users you update your
policy based on the data so far and you
keep doing this trial for capital t time
periods okay
so the simplified view of this world is
you have observed data for all users
till time t minus one that determines
the policy at time t you have some
unobserved potential outcomes and noise
variables
so a policy pi t decides which
treatments are assigned to which users
at time t and unobserved variables and
the policy together decide what outcomes
are observed at time t
and then this data put together decides
to policy at the next time
you don't have to update the policy
every day but like every once in a while
you do update it so this is the design
and the policy here is adaptive so that
you can personalize to different users
so as to make the application effective
and in practice sometimes you start
pooling data during the study so note
how i write here all end users that is
being done to reduce the noise so that
you can learn the policy quickly
otherwise if the users get frustrated
they might delete the app and they might
just unenroll themselves from the trial
so so there are two things here the
policy is known to you it's adaptive and
it's being designed using
all the data that you have observed
across users
and some questions after the trial is
over
general questions of interest would be
what was the treatment effect or like
what was the effectiveness of sending a
notification was there heterogeneity
across users what was the treatment
effect at time t
all these kind of generic questions can
be asked
our goal in this talk would be
counterfactual inference
by that i mean estimation of missing
potential outcomes which is a hard task
in general because of heterogeneity
across users and time
and you can imagine that if we can
estimate all the missing potential
outcomes we can perhaps do generic after
study analysis but that part will not be
the focus of the talk here
we'll assume that this is our goal to
estimate all the missing data
and heterogeneity makes it hard also the
fact that you have adaptivity and
pooling of uses
during the trial itself to design the
policy makes it even more challenging
okay
and i will illustrate why what i mean by
this
so the next few slides the outline will
be like this we'll we'll look at the
settings considering prior work
there's a rich prior work with these
adaptive policies i'll try to
differentiate how this setup is slightly
different
and then we'll talk about our
contributions namely we'll give a
non-parametric strategy and then prove
some sort of uh consistency and central
limit theorem results under certain
assumptions
so that will be the rest of the talk
so
our setting is as follows just to recap
again we have n users time t tilt time
capital t
and the data determines the policy you
observe policy observations at time t
then you use that information and the
pass information to decide your policy
so this might remind you of something
like the dynamic treatment regime in
longitudinal studies
note that the way these boxes have
changed is now we have one user
so these
these dynamic treatment regime problems
they focus on adaptive policies for a
single fixed user over time so this is
like you're tracking an individual this
medical history and based on their
history and how they've responded to the
treatments you're adapting the
treatments in an online manner
and you have this kind of experiments
independent across users
so unlike our setup where we have end
users the trial index runs
simultaneously on them here the trial is
being run independently and separately
for each user
in the recent literature on bandits uh
the
the work the setup is like this it's
like id users over time so it's like an
ad setting
you have your performance your policy
till time t minus one that informs your
uh the data observability management
informs your policy at time t
and then you have a new user you use
that information to update your policy
so here the users are changing over time
so you have adaptive policies but it's
not about the same users
over multiple time instances
and then in causal panel data you have
multiple users simultaneously for
multiple times but generally the
treatment is assigned only once and
there is no real discussion of policy in
the literature and often it's unobserved
so it's more like the unconfoundedness
assumption and that kind of a setting so
it's again different than what we are
trying to deal in this talk
so you might ask okay so what do you do
so we reduce in this setting counter
fractional inference to a sequential
matrix completion problem
meaning that
uh i will i'll assume that we have
finitely many treatments and let's fix a
treatment for example one
now we have n by t matrix of potential
outcomes that we're interested in and we
only observe some of them based on which
user was assigned action one at time t
in particular the observation model now
can be written as z i t
is y star i t here y star i t is the
outcome corresponding to treatment that
you fixed
plus noise
if the action was one and unknown if the
action was zero
and the actions here are being assigned
using a bernoulli flips
using the policy at time t
okay and this policy is adaptive as i
said using the data pass data
so now once you've reduced to this
setting the new goal is estimating the
missing entries y star i t and we'll as
i said we'll do it separately for each
treatment so going forward we only have
one treatment at a time that's what i'll
talk about
so the rest of the talk will be
having reduced to sequential matrix
completion how do you estimate it and
when will this estimate be any good
under what conditions can we show
anything for this in general a hard
problem
so
to estimate the missing data we use the
variant of nearest neighbors
so this is a matrix of n by t
y axis is the users t axis is the time
blue boxes denotes the observed data the
gray well here it looks like white white
denotes the missing data and suppose we
are interested in estimating that
particular entry y i t star i a throat
column
so to estimate that the first step in
nearest neighbors is
look at the users that are available at
that time meaning that their outcome was
observed at time t
now restrict only to those users
and then
compare the rows of
any available user with the user i
look at the time instance where both of
them have a simultaneous observation so
these are four time instances in this
particular example
compute the square error distance
between these two rows
limited to those indices
that is the distance rho t i j so at
time t
between user i and user j when you are
trying to estimate y i t star
so that's
the estimate is now very simple
it's
average
the outcome of available users whose
distance rho tij is less than eta it is
some suitably chosen constant
so it's a very simple estimate
find available users at time t
then look at their distance from user i
if it is less than eta just average over
all the available users
if you don't have any any if this set is
empty then you can choose a default
value of 0 or mean over the entire set
of observations
so eta in our theoretical bounds will
track the dependence on eta in practice
one can use some sort of cross
validation on the observed entries
themselves so there is a practical way
of tuning eta but for now we can assume
that eta is given to us and we'll track
it in our theoretical results
so not a very special property of this
estimate it's completely model and
policy agnostic
like i'm not using propensity weights
i'm not using anything so you don't need
to know the pi ts to construct this
estimator and i'm not making any
parametric assumptions on the model also
so it's very agnostic and you might
wonder
will it even work
isn't it too general for it to work
and the talk this second part of the
talk is no it is general but it still
works if you have some sort of a latent
factor model assumptions and suitable
conditions
yes
so why yes so when i so when i'm fixing
y t star i'm assuming that you unit i at
time t has a unique outcome associated
with action that particular treatment
yes so there is no spillover in the
future that is correct
and it will become more clear when i
present the next one thank you
so
so what is the latent factor model that
we assume let me go on this slide
slightly slowly
so y i t star is the quantity of
interest
and you can assume that or you can think
of it as the outcome of user i at time t
for treatment 1
and we model it as a function of ui and
vt
unknown function and these ui and vt are
latent factors so we don't need to know
any of them
ui represents the later factor for user
i and vt represents the latent factor
for time t and f is unknown potential
nonlinear function
so this answer this is a partial answer
to your question for different
treatments
we'll assume a different f ui vt and you
can repeat the entire machinery to get
an estimate so that's how it's done
separately for each treatment but there
is no
there is some sort of stationarity but
at the same time non-stationarity that i
will become clear now so let's visualize
what this means
so y axis is the end user latent factors
x axis is the
time latent factors
so at time one this model is saying that
the outcome of unit 1 at time 1 is a
function of its unit its latent user
factor u1 and v1
and yn1 star is a function of un and v1
so you can see that
v1 determines has like induces
correlations across this whole column
although each user has a different way
of taking a different snapshot of v1
because of that potential nonlinear
function
and then across time
the uh user one's outcomes are given by
as a function of u1 v1 at time 1
u1 v2 at time 2 and u1 vt at time
capital t
so you can see that this kind of
structure means
the outcomes are correlated so if you
fix a time they're correlated because
the latent factor of time is fixed if i
fix a user they're correlated across
time because
uh the user latent factor is fixed so
it's a special kind of correlation
nonetheless it is still a
good model in the sense that even if
these factors are iid the outcomes are
not id
because of this structure
okay
so this is now you might ask why is this
structure interesting other than
correlation
well in these kind of tracks often you
use gaussian processes to model the
outcomes and gaussian process is a
special case of this particular latent
factor model so if if y i star so the
outcomes of a particular user across
time are a draw from a gaussian process
with kernel k
then ui denotes a gaussian vector
and v t denote the eigen functions so
vector corresponding to eigen functions
of k
and this f is actually a bilinear
function
the the size of these vectors depends on
the rank of the kernel
and also this setup subsumes
a subclass of exchangeable data like so
if your matrix has exchangeable rows and
columns a subclass of that data is
covered under latent factor model
so it's fairly general and as i said f
doesn't have to be
linear per se for our guarantees
so now i have told you that reduce the
problem to matrix completion then use
nearest neighbors and i've introduced
the latent factor model
now the point is like what can you do
what can you say with this kind of a
structure
so let me first start with the bilinear
case then i'll go to the nonlinear case
so in the bilinear case meaning that if
the outcomes are given as
f of u comma v is an inner product
between u and v
then for any pair i t so any user i at
time t
remember the run of the experiment is
capital t so small t is some index in
between
if it has enough if it has enough
nearest neighbors enough neighbors that
satisfy two conditions
first condition is
that the latent time factors are diverse
enough
meaning that uh if i take the latent
factors can make their covanese matrix
it is positive definite with an
eigenvalue smaller greater than lambda
and the sum indices are the common
observed time points
so remember we were constructing the
distances we are looking at when both
units had a
commonly observed data point
look at the latent factors on those time
points and construct their covariance
that should have a minimum eigenvalue so
this is talking about that your latent
factors are diverse enough
and the second assumption is if your
noise is non-adversarial so we had
epsilons in our noise outcome model
so if our noise is not adversarial
because you have these adaptive sampling
mechanisms
it can be adversarial so if it behaves
roughly like iid or mixing process
despite the adaptivity
then
for suitable scaling of threshold eta
and mild conditions on
the policy so in this case actually
policy can be arbitrary it doesn't even
have to be sequential
for a given unit
conditioned on its latent factor ui we
have a consistency result
that our estimate goes to iit star for
any t
not just the last t it's like i'm going
back in time to impute everything
so we have a consistency result as the
number of units and the time goes to
infinity yes
um
this diverse latent time factors uh
in here
is the matrix on the left-hand side a
random one and if so then is this like
does this have to hold with with with
probability
one or what's the
you know good question yeah yeah so
this is we are trying to give uh you
should think of this as a deterministic
assumption
so if you want to make distributional
assumptions then the statement here will
depend on when this condition holds if
this holds with high probability this
will hold it by probability if as t goes
to infinity this is probability one then
this will hold with probability one so
it's like an if and then kind of a
convention okay so here we are not
making any distribution of assumptions
we are just giving you the two objects
that have to behave in a nice way but
this is a random name this is yeah so if
uh if you condition on everything it's
determining if you're not then yes it is
a random quantity so you can think of
this as going to the eigenvalue of the
population
level covariance and that if population
level covariance is well behaved then
this will be better
if the samples are enough okay
thank you yes
no this is for
this is for a fixed eye and
you can do you yeah so this is if this
holds for all t then this will hold for
rt when will this hold for volte that's
the
so you need conditions to make it a
uniform probabilistic convergence but if
you have this quantity then yes it will
be uniform but here we are assuming that
the user is space so and we are proving
convergence one by one yes what's the
what's the rate for the threshold
constant yeah oh so for that i will have
to use my additional slide we can do
that during questions
is there any condition of the user
latency
[Music]
not not in this slide now let me tell
you why this will work in the next slide
so
you'll see why it was if the latent
factors are diverse enough and the noise
is non-adversarial what ends up
happening is that if the distance is
less than eta
you have this ui minus uj times the
matrix times ui minus you just sitting
there so it indirectly implies that ui
minus uj have to be less than root eta
by lambda where lambda is that minimum
eigenvalue
and once you have that the user latent
factors are close
then the outcomes are closed because we
have bilinearity and we can also handle
approximate bilinearity for the same
reason so you can now see that if this
lambda is zero this bound is vacuous
and why do we need many users because we
have noisy outcomes so you need to
average across the users to kill the
noise
and yeah so that's that's the rough
intuition what is going on why this
bound will work
yes
why are you following the sequential
matrix completion this part is uh
this part handles sequential uh as a
subset it's more general than that the
next part is only about sequential so
i'll explain it in the next slide okay
oh if i if i assume that i i think i
might be missing something here if i
assume that f of u v is by linear like
this does that imply that my matrix of
y's is correctly rank one or why is it
not rank one is what i want one one to
wondering because you have uis and v
keys so it's a matrix of u times v each
of them will depend on the rank of the
latest factor so it's a rank r matrix if
that is the dimension of your related
factors
it's not rank one
all right so coming to the sequential
part and slightly stronger guarantee
so if that is not linear now we assume
it's a general nonlinear function as
long as it's slip shapes
and suppose we have these additional
distributional conditions and these are
needed to
provide a stronger guarantee so previous
result was just a consistency result
here we'll be showing a central limit
theorem so we are also characterizing
the fluctuations
so if the unit latent factors are iid
the time latent factors are id the noise
doesn't have to be iid but
it's independent with mean zero and
variance sigma square and your pi t is
sequential in the sense that pi t
depends only on the history till t minus
one
so this is the sequential part and the
treatments are assigned conditionally
independent given the history
then
we can show that under regularity
condition which i will elaborate for any
given user with latent user
factor ui
at last time t
and the number of nearest neighbors nit
[Music]
you have the right central limit theorem
that
the estimate minus the true thing
root nit goes to normal zero sigma
square as the n and t go to infinity now
they have to go together at a suitable
rate that will become clear later
so this is where sequential part comes
in because if you have an experiment of
size n by t we can only tell you
guarantee at time t so you can think of
you run the experimental time t
construct confidence intervals make a
decision and continue so that's the
sequential part yes
none of this is about deciding the
policy to force these positions right
this is just completely based on like if
you have yes
so this that is correct we are not
designing policies that's a great
question you're just saying that if your
policy comes from
in most sequential experiment it
satisfies these properties then these
conditions hold like this results yes
policies
well people are actually already running
trial with such policies when they use
like band-aids data or multiplicative
weights based on past data so they
update some sort of treatment of whether
i should treat user eye with treatment
one with higher probability or not based
on positive so they are already doing it
so i would say this is fairly generally
already being done what we are trying to
say is despite these kind of conditions
we are still able to do some sort of
counterfactual inference under a latent
factor model and these assumptions
sorry sorry it's just one quick comment
so if you take questions from an
audience now can you just repeat them
for the people who are online because
they might not hear slice with a
microphone okay okay all right so
uh the question was
uh
are we are we uh
are you trying to tell how to design
these policies the answer is no and the
question was is it clear how to design
such policies and the answer is yes
because it's already being done in
practice using all kind of rl algorithms
to run these trials so in those settings
pi t actually satisfies this assumption
this one in particular this is debatable
that's like modeling assumption yes ben
the number of neighbors is busy
it depends on threshold yes
you're assuming that
that's right yeah so let's go to the
next slide to see
how what this means here everything is
going to infinity it's not clear who is
going where so let's see on the next
slide
so to understand who is going where we
need to write a non-asymptotic bound and
we prove this in the paper too so now
i'm talking about an expected squared
error bound on y hat i t capital t
minus y star i t given the user unit
factor i
expectation is over all the other
randomness you can potentially condition
on vt if you want to but we don't
here and then we have three terms on the
bound one is this first term is the bias
due to the eta
the second term is concentration of
neighbor distance i will explain all
these terms in a bit and the third term
is
because you are averaging over many
users to estimate the outcome the noise
variance goes down so that's the
variance term so these are the three
terms first two terms behave like the
bias term actually
so what is p minty here it's the minimum
sampling probability of any entry till
time t
so that is p minty
what is phi i that's the phi is sitting
here
that's the probability of sampling a
good neighbor a prime so before you run
the trial we have the end users
what is the probability that you you had
one good user in that
uh
for for user i you had one good user to
begin with that's this probability
and then this mysterious and slightly
complicated term gamma i t
that captures the effect of
your sequence of adaptive policies pi t
in a stability sense it's hard to parse
it but let me try
it is saying that look at the joint
probabilities of
i and j being treated at time t prime
conditional history at t and subtract it
with the same thing condition in history
t minus one
so the only difference between the two
terms is what you are conditioning on
and the difference is just one column
so this bound is meaningful only when
gamma i t
upon p mean square root t doesn't like
diverge it goes to zero
in other words we want this gamma i t to
grow slowly than the denominator
or we want to say that the policy is
adaptive in a stable manner it's not
adapting too quickly five minutes okay
great i'm almost on track
so the policy is not adapting too
quickly
that's this meaning of gamma i t being
small
and so now we have this squared error
bound
to establish central limit theorem we'll
multiply the whole thing by the n i t
the number of nearest neighbors
and we'll only care about the bias
should go up to zero
so oh before that sorry uh maybe i'll
come to this later yeah so for the for
the central limit theorem to hold
what i will do is i'll multiply
effectively i'm multiplying this by nit
so this thing gets multiplied by nit
this thing gets multiplied by nit you
can ignore this one for me for a moment
so this should go to 0 after multiplying
by the number of nearest neighbor that
means the eta has to go to 0 fast enough
and
if you multiply here then you have nit
in the numerator and root t in the
denominator meaning that the number of
nearest neighbors at time they should be
capital t doesn't go faster than p
square means root t
so
i can explain in the discussion
afterwards like why this kind of a
condition arises here
but in a nutshell we can make sure that
this happens by capping the number of
nearest neighbors for theoretical
analysis we can always cap to get a
bound on how quickly p minty can go to
zero and things like that so it's
possible to send this to zero at the
right scaling of eta
p mean t and uh by capping the number of
nearest neighbors so that's the bias
term goes to zero this is the variance
term so once you multiply by nit
actually this is the nit term sitting
there so you have that sigma square and
so for central limit term to work
basically you need the denominator to go
to infinity and that will go to infinity
if phi i's and p minty are like the
right like they scale currently
that's it
so that's the whole talk
we were talking about sequential
experiments
where
trials are run for capital time t you
have n users and you pull across all the
users
information to
update your policies and the question is
can we do counterfactual inference
i presented a simple nearest neighbor
estimate and then i showed that or at
least i
told you believe me that under latent
factor model
if you have by linearity under suitable
conditions
you have consistency result for any user
and any arbitrary time
and if you have ellipses non-linear f
then you have a central limit theorem
for the last time point
and
scaling by the number of nearest
neighbors
you might have many questions
and
want to put a disclaimer that this is
just a starting point as i said i'm
relatively new to this topic it's very
exciting
we have no context or features or
covariates in this setup that's one
thing to do how to incorporate that
information
i said we are interested in counter
factual inference and i said that we are
interested in estimating all missing
outcomes but so once we estimate it what
do we do with it what's the effect of
that that's another question
i'm assuming id and i'm not putting any
structure on how the latent time factors
are evolving over time or how the user
is evolving over time or how the user is
being impacted by treatment as the
question was from the audience
that is not being used
and i have separated counterfactual
inference for each treatment to a
separate matrix completion problem so i
am not leveraging information across
treatments
that is another
so because this is in my head this was
like our first attempt to find when can
we do it and now try to
uh unpack its further consequences
and preprint i submitted on archive
today so hopefully it will be
online
later today
thank you
all right thank you very much for the
nice talk so
i think it's good if we hold further
questions for the panel discussion later
and now have our break so we're going to
continue a half an hour with a talk by
jamie